Lo hemos contado ya aquí en VisualPolitik,
Argentina es algo así como el país donde
el fútbol es prácticamente una religión
de estado; y donde no pasa una sola década
sin que se produzca al menos una gran crisis
económica.
Durante décadas este país ha estado dominado
por un modelo político, una especie de ideología,
una corriente política, el peronismo, que
es algo así como la suma de nacionalismo,
proteccionismo y gasto público.
"Nosotros, y cuando hablo de nosotros hablo del movimiento político al que pertenezco,
yo sí, del peronismo sí."
Pero en 2015 llegó un nuevo gobierno, el
de Mauricio Macri, con la misión de reconstruir
el país de arriba abajo.
"Yo, Mauricio Macri, juro por Dios, nuestro señor, y estos santos evangelios,
desempeñar con lealtad y honestidad el cargo de Presidente de la nación argentina".
En las elecciones legislativas de 2017, el
pueblo argentino ha revalidado su confianza
en este proceso. Por decirlo de alguna forma,
le ha venido a decir: ¡Bien hecho, Macri!
Así que, amigos, la pregunta que empieza
a estar en el aire es ¿Está Argentina por
fin, de una vez por todas, lista para despegar?
Veámoslo.
El pasado 22 de octubre de 2017 se celebraron
elecciones al Congreso y al Senado en Argentina.
La coalición de gobierno, Cambiemos, con más
de 10 millones de votos tuvo un triunfo...
aplastante.
Ganó en 15 de los 24 distritos electorales,
incluyendo los 5 principales, los más poblados:
La Provincia de Buenos Aires, ciudad de Buenos
Aires, Córdoba, Santa Fé y Mendoza.
No ocurría algo así, ni más ni menos, que
desde 1985.
Ahora, tras estas elecciones, Cambiemos está
cerca de la mayoría absoluta, lo que le asegura
al gobierno poder sacar adelante su agenda
de reformas.
"Hoy estamos acá, no porque estemos en contra de nadie, nosotros no somos anti nadie,
estamos a favor de nuestro futuro porque creemos que merecemos vivir mejor".
Por eso, amigos, son muchos los analistas
que afirman que ahora comienza de verdad el
mandato de Macri.
Ahora bien, tras 2 años el poder, ¿Qué
ha hecho Mauricio Macri? ¿Qué no ha hecho?
¿Cuales son son sus intenciones?
¿Realmente puede Argentina
convertirse en el país de moda? Lo vamos
a ver en este vídeo, pero antes veamos un
poquito de historia.
(EL DECLIVE)
Hace un siglo, Argentina era uno de los países
más ricos del mundo, más rico incluso que
países como Canadá, Australia, Francia o
la mismísima Alemania.
(Y no solo eso, el 8 de mayo de 1945, al terminar
la Segunda Guerra Mundial, Argentina era junto
a Estados Unidos, uno de los mayores acreedores
mundiales y también uno de los mayores propietarios
de oro de todo el planeta.)
En aquel momento, amigos, Buenos Aires estaba
en pleno auge y era capaz de rivalizar con
la mismísima Nueva York.
[Algo que os aseguro
queda muy claro cuando visitais está fantástica
ciudad por primera vez]
Pero claro, dicho esto puede que te estés
preguntando: ¿Qué diantres le ocurrió a la Argentina?
Pues mirad, a pesar de que las cosas para
este país no pintaban nada mal tras la Segunda
Guerra Mundial, lo cierto es que algo estaba
ya cambiando…
(La gran crisis internacional de los años
30, afectó mucho al país, Argentina que
era un gran exportador de productos agrícolas
sufrió la debacle del comercio internacional
y su primera gran crisis financiera. Desde
entonces nada volvió a ser lo mismo.)
La política, amigos, comenzó a intervenir
todos los campos de la economía y la sociedad.
Y finalmente en 1946 comenzó lo que podemos
llamar el viraje definitivo… el gobierno
del General Farrell, primero, y del Coronel
Juan Domingo Perón, después, aprobaron todo
tipo de normas y leyes, ojo, más de 16.000
decretos-leyes, que de facto pusieron a la
economía bajo el control del estado.
(Cosas como el comercio exterior, la creación
de empresas o la competencia quedaron en un
segundo plano. En su lugar políticas como
la sustitución de importaciones, las nacionalizaciones
o las grandes empresas estatales fueron el
patrón dominante en esa nueva Argentina.)
Y así comenzó, amigos, toda una cuesta abajo
de 70 años que hizo que Argentina se convirtiese
en uno de los pocos países que ha pasado
de ser un país desarrollado, a ser un país
en vías de desarrollo.
Conceptos como crisis, hiperinflación o suspensión
de pagos han sido temas muy habituales en
los medios de comunicación argentinos en
estas últimas décadas.
Y este proceso,, tuvo como colofón al kirchnerismo,
especialmente en su última etapa, en la de
Cristina Fernández de Kirchner.
(CÓMO ARRUINAR UN PAÍS)
A lo largo de sus dos mandatos como presidenta,
Cristina Fernández de Kirchner puso en pie
un modelo que podría definirse, sencillamente,
como antieconómico.
Sí, Argentina ya era una país terrible para
los negocios… pero Cristina fue un paso
más allá.
(En la Argentina de CFK había controles de
capitales, las empresas no podían repatriar
sus beneficios, los impuestos a las empresas
alcanzaron proporciones no comparables en
Latinoamérica, había muchísimas restricciones
a las importaciones y el Banco Central se
dedicó a darle a la máquina de crear dinero
para financiar al gobierno.)
El modelo eran tan terriblemente antieconómico,
amigos, que Cristina puso un montón de impuestos
a las exportaciones, tal cual como lo escucháis.
[¿A quien se le puede ocurrir castigar a
las empresas que se dedican a exportar,
a vender a otros países ¡De locos!
Pero no solo eso, con Cristina al frente de la
Casa Rosada, la Casa Blanca argentina, este
país se convirtió en uno de los más proteccionistas
de toda Latinoamérica y también en un país
donde montar empresas era algo rematadamente
difícil.
Y claro, el resultado de todo esto no se hizo
esperar:
durante su segundo mandato el crecimiento
fue nulo, el déficit público se disparó,
la inflación subió al 40%, la inversión
se desplomó y de repente, otra vez, nada
parecía funcionar.
Bajo este panorama es como en diciembre de
2015 los argentinos eligieron a Mauricio Macri,
antiguo presidente del Boca Junior, como nuevo
Presidente de Argentina.
"Quiero ser el presidente que pueda acompañarlos en su crecimiento.
El presidente del desarrollo del potencial de cada argentino."
(LA LLEGADA DE MACRI)
El primer año de Macri al frente
de Argentina no fue nada, pero que nada fácil.
Claro, si al terrible estado en el que Cristina
Fernández de Kirchner dejó el país, le
añadimos todos los efectos de las reformas…
por ejemplo, la reducción de los subsidios
a la electricidad o al gas natural; cuyos
frutos nunca son inmediatos, es fácil entender
que los primeros meses fuesen tan complicados.
Atentos.
(En 2016 el país sufrió una dura recesión
con una caída del PIB del 2,6%; la inflación
se acercó al 40%, aumentó la pobreza, el
desempleo, el déficit y la deuda externa.)
En otras palabras, no faltaron oportunidades
para atizarle a Macri… ¿Este era acaso
el cambio prometido?
Bien, ya hemos dicho que las reformas no tienen
porque tener resultados inmediatos, pero al
final llegan.
(Por fin, en 2017, la economía argentina
está dando síntomas de mejora. Es probable
que el crecimiento de este año supere el
3% y el apetito inversor ya es más que evidente.)
Sí, así es, parece que Argentina puede estar
llegando a la salida de un largo túnel .
De momento estos resultados le han dado a Macri
el gran triunfo electoral que hemos visto.
Ahora bien, ¿Qué qué es lo que hizo exactamente
este presidente?
Pues... básicamente reducir todas esas regulaciones
y políticas tan… como decirlo... disparatadas
y antieconómicas,
(El nuevo gobierno se puso pronto manos a
la obra, no había tiempo que perder. Nada
más llegar eliminó los controles de divisas;
permitió que los inversores extranjeros pudieran
repatriar sus beneficios; eliminó la mayoría
de los incomprensibles impuestos a la exportación
y redujo los subsidios y las restricciones
a las importaciones. Todo con un objetivo:
Argentina tiene que recuperar la economía
productiva.)
También, importantísimo, por un lado Macri
llegó a un acuerdo con parte de los inversores
internacionales a los que Argentina había
impagado en 2001 y con los que aún se mantenían
peleas judiciales;
(“Argentina llega a un acuerdo con los fondos
buitre tras 14 años de pugna. En total, para
cubrir todas las deudas con los fondos, Macri
ofrece 6.500 millones de dólares. El acuerdo
implica una quita del 25%” El País.)
Por otro lado, el nuevo gobierno aprobó una
especie de regularización, de amnistía fiscal,
que saco a La Luz, atentos, ni más ni menos
que 117.000 millones de dólares que los argentinos
tenían en el extranjero y no habían declarado.
[Ojo, antes de escandalizarse. Pensad que
harías vosotros si tuvierais miedo a que
vuestros ahorros pudieran ser confiscados
por el gobierno. A veces no solo es una cuestión
de pagar menos impuestos. Cuando los estados
no tienen seguridad jurídica, es muy fácil
que el dinero simplemente huya]
El caso, amigos, es que con todas estas medidas,
el gobierno de Macri consiguió que el dinero
volviera a fijarse en Argentina.
Y desde entonces se ha producido toda una
lluvia de dinero que, por ejemplo, está disparando
el sector inmobiliario o la venta de coches.
("Estamos batiendo récords, más de 780.000
autos vendidos al dia de hoy y, lo más importante,
récord de camiones. Eso significa que la
producción se está moviendo, que la construcción
se está moviendo" Mauricio Macri.)
Vamos, que el motor, nunca mejor dicho parece
haber vuelto a arrancar.
(“Volkswagen invertirá US$650M para modernizar
plantas en Argentina” América Economía.)
Pero una pregunta, amigos… ¿Realmente creéis
que está siendo todo tan...modélico,
tan bonito?
Pues esperad un momento, porque lo cierto
es que hasta ahora las reformas han sido muy,pero
que muy graduales y con un alcance bastante
corto;
algo que a pesar de los resultados electorales
y de todas estas llamadas a descorchar el
champán ha puesto en alerta a muchos expertos.
(“A la hora de la verdad por el momento
no ha hecho demasiado, más allá de apartar
al kirchnerismo del poder, que no es poco
[...] Aunque ha dicho que estas elecciones
son el aval para las reformas, no se sabe
muy bien en qué consisten, qué quiere hacer”.
Carlos Rodríguez Braun.)
Pero, ¿por qué tanta desconfianza?
Pues porque a pesar de las reformas que hemos
visto parece que a este gobierno le está
costando superar algunas de las típicas adiciones
de los gobiernos argentinos.
Por ejemplo, el gasto público no solo no
se ha reducido sino que sigue subiendo, lo
que ha provocado, entre otras cosas, que la
deuda exterior se dispare en este breve tiempo
en más de 50.000 millones de dólares.
(Y eso no es todo: los impuestos siguen por
las nubes; el banco central continúa financiando
al gobierno con nuevo dinero, esto es, monetizando
deuda; y según el último informe Doing Business,
que mide la facilidad para hacer negocios
en un país, Argentina sigue en la cola, concretamente
en el puesto 116.)
Eso sí, para ser justos, podemos decir que
hasta ahora Macri ha tenido dos buenas “excusas”:
primero que ha pasado poco tiempo; y segundo
que su posición política en el congreso
y en el senado eran muy débiles.
Ahora, tras las últimas elecciones todo eso
se ha terminado.
(UNA AGENDA REFORMISTA)
Parece que tras su aplastante triunfo electoral
el presidente Macri, lo tiene claro:
(“Entramos en una etapa de reformismo permanente.
Argentina no tiene que parar y no tienen que
tenerle miedo a las reformas porque reformarse
es crecer, evolucionar, progresar".
Mauricio Macri.)
Por delante le queda una tarea… complicada.
Pero ¿Cuáles son sus prioridades?
Pues fundamentalmente, amigos, al principio
algo que puede ser tan impopular como necesario:
reducir el déficit público y controlar la
inflación, lo que en última instancia son
cosas relacionadas.
Luego conseguir que Argentina sea un país
competitivo y atractivo para invertir.
Para lograrlo ha prometido aprobar una reforma
fiscal que reduzca los impuestos a las empresas,
una reforma laboral que facilite la contratación
y más acuerdos de libre comercio.
(“Argentina y Chile firman el más ambicioso
acuerdo de libre comercio en 20 años”.)
Luego también la reforma de las pensiones,
la reforma educativa, las infraestructuras.
Sí, podemos decir que a Macri le queda mucho
trabajo si quiere cumplir con las altísimas
expectativas que se han depositado en él.
En cualquier caso, parece que sí, que esta
vez un nuevo tiempo político y económico
ha comenzado para Argentina. Una buena muestra
es la apuesta de Macri por lograr reducir
la pobreza formalizando y extendiendo la propiedad
entre los más desfavorecidos.
(“Argentina entrega “certificados de vivienda”
a 1,5 millones de personas de villas miseria.
El Gobierno de Macri les dará los documentos
para acceder a agua y luz de forma legal”.)
De esto, por cierto, de cómo combatir la
pobreza hablaremos en un próximo vídeo.
Pero ahora la pregunta es ¿Se pondrá este
país de moda? Si profundiza en las reformas
y consigue aprovechar todas las oportunidades,
como por ejemplo la industria del litio de
la que también os hemos hablado aquí, no
me cabe la menor duda.
Pero qué pensáis vosotros ¿Conseguirá
Argentina convertirse en un motor para latinoamérica?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte al canal.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.